lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es un
repaso rápido al crecimiento exponencial
y luego usar esto como nuestra
plataforma para introducirnos al
decaimiento exponencial así que
empecemos por repasar el crecimiento
exponencial digamos que tenemos una
tabla por aquí entonces digamos que esta
es nuestra equis y esta es nuestra yema
y ahora voy a decir que cuando x es
igual a 0 james es igual a 3 y cada vez
que aumentamos x en 1 vamos a duplicar
el valor anterior así que se va a ir de
3 a 6 si x aumenta en 1 y si x aumenta
en una otra vez tenemos x igualados
entonces vamos a duplicar de nuevo y me
quedaría 6 x 2 lo cual es 2 a esto hasta
aquí es un crecimiento exponencial
incluso podemos ir con x negativas por
ejemplo cuando x es igual a menos 1
estamos yendo uno hacia atrás de x igual
a 0 y por lo tanto vamos a dividir entre
que esto va a ser que igual a tres
medios y noten que si van de menos 1 a 0
de nuevo lo que están haciendo es
multiplicar por 2 y todo esto lo pueden
escribir con una ecuación pueden decir
que james es igual y bueno algunas veces
la gente puede llamar esto su
intersección en james o su valor inicial
que va a ser igual al valor inicial que
es 3 que es esencialmente lo que sucede
cuando x es igual a cero por una razón
común y nuestra razón común es por lo
que multiplicamos cada vez que
aumentamos x en uno entonces me quedaría
y es igual a tres por nuestra razón
común que es 2 elevado a la potencia x y
puedes verificarlo
por ejemplo escoger en algún número para
ejes cuando x es igual a 2 va a ser 3
que multiplican a 2 elevado al cuadrado
que es 3 por 4 que es igual a 12 y es
justo lo que estábamos obteniendo y
podemos ver esto en una gráfica así que
permite dibujar rápido
una gráfica por aquí veamos este va a
ser mi eje x este va a ser mi eje y van
a estar a una escala ligeramente
diferente entonces este es mi eje x y
voy a ir de menos 1 a 0 a 1 a 2 y veamos
en el eje y bueno hasta arriba tenemos
el 12 entonces vamos a ir de 3 en 3 369
y por acá tenemos al 12 y sólo podemos
graficar estos puntos en la tabla
por ejemplo cuando x es igual a menos
uno tenemos que james es igual a tres
medios así que estaríamos por aquí
cuando x es igual a 0 que sería igual a
3 estaríamos por aquí cuando x es igual
a 1 se ha duplicado ahora entonces
tenemos 6 y cuando x es igual a 210
igual a 12 y por lo tanto pueden ver
esta curva que estoy haciendo
ahora hay un par de características
claves de las que ya hemos hablado en
algunos vídeos si van aumentando los
valores negativos en x entonces tendrás
como asiento está al eje x es decir
nunca vas a llegar al cero sin importar
qué valor negativo te tomes aunque sea
el más grande que pienses te vas a
aproximar pero nunca tocaras el cero y
cuando tengas más y más y más valores
positivos de x bueno solamente se
disparará hasta infinito esto lo hemos
hablado en vídeos anteriores y de hecho
también hemos dicho que para cualquier
función lineal esta gráfica
eventualmente la va a pasar va a ser
mayor que cualquier función lineal ahora
vamos a comparar esto con el decaimiento
exponencial y déjame escribir el
decaimiento exponencial
una manera fácil de plantearlo es que en
lugar de crecer cada vez que estemos
aumentando a x lo que vamos a hacer es
disminuir una cierta cantidad va a
decaer así que vamos a hacer otra tabla
aquí con valores de x de 10 tenemos por
aquí a x tenemos por aquí hay y entonces
vamos a empezar voy a decir que cuando x
es igual a 0 que va a valer lo mismo
lleva a valer 3 pero esta vez en lugar
de duplicar cada vez que aumentemos x en
1 lo que vamos a hacer es dividir por 2
o multiplicar por un medio entonces cada
vez que aumentamos x en 1 cuando tenemos
aquí es igual a 1 voy a multiplicar por
un medio y vamos a llegar a tres medios
y cuando x es igual a 2
voy a multiplicar por un medio otra vez
y entonces voy a llegar a tres cuartos y
así sucesivamente y si tuviéramos que ir
con valores negativos entonces pensemos
qué pasa cuando x vale menos uno bien si
vamos hacia atrás en x por uno lo que
vamos a hacer es
dividir ahora entre un medio y entonces
llegaríamos a seis oyendo desde menos
uno a cero aumentaríamos x en uno y de
nuevo estaríamos multiplicando por un
medio entonces como escribiríamos esto
como una ecuación bueno pues te invito a
que pausa es el vídeo y veas si puedes
escribirlo en una forma similar
bien va a verse algo así james va a ser
igual y primero recuerda vamos a poner
la intersección en yemen o dicho de otra
manera el valor de que cuando x es igual
a 0 que en este caso de nuevo es 3 y
ahora hay que multiplicarlo por la razón
común que en este caso es un medio
observan estamos multiplicando por un
medio entonces me quedaría un médium ya
esto lo vamos a elevar a la potencia x y
observa ambas ecuaciones tanto la
primera como la segunda son ecuaciones
exponenciales podrán decir que tenemos
la intersección en james o un valor
inicial exactamente igual y estamos
multiplicando por alguna razón común
elevada a la potencia x pero noten
cuando estamos creciendo tenemos que
nuestra razón común o más bien el valor
absoluto de la razón común va a ser
mayor que 1 entonces el valor absoluto
en este caso de 2 es mayor que 1 en
nuestra primera exponencial y por lo
tanto nuestra función está creciendo
y en el caso en el que está disminuyendo
el valor absoluto de la razón común debe
de ser menor que 1 y esto tiene sentido
ya que si multiplicas algo con el valor
absoluto menor que 1 no sé como un medio
en este caso o como tres cuartos o como
un 0.9 cada vez que multiplique es por
ese valor vas a obtener un valor más
bajo y más bajo y más bajo en tu función
en realidad puedes ver esto en la
gráfica vamos a hacer la gráfica si
pongo esta información en la misma
gráfica me voy a obtener que cuando x es
igual a menos 1
llévales 6 cuando x es igual a 0
otra vez estoy en de igual a tres cuando
x vale uno que vale tres medios y cuando
x vale dos que vale tres cuartos y así
sucesivamente y noten que ya que
nuestras razones comunes son recíprocas
entre sí entonces estas dos gráficas se
ven como si estuvieran volteadas la una
a la otra de manera horizontal volteada
sobre el eje y es decir son simétricas
alrededor del eje y
y lo que verán en decaimiento
exponencial es que las cosas serán más
más en más pequeñas pero nunca llegarán
a hacer exactamente igual a cero se van
a aproximar a cero eso sí pero tendrán
como asiento está el eje x y eso cuando
se vuelvan más y más y más positivas
como pasaba en el crecimiento
exponencial cuando x se volvía más y más
y más negativa es decir son a sin todas
al eje x y bueno toda este era una
introducción un vídeo de introducción en
el que he usado un ejemplo muy
específico pero en general si tienen la
ecuación de la forma de igual
por alguna razón común o r a la potencia
x esto va a ser un crecimiento
exponencial si el valor absoluto de r es
mayor que 1 en este caso estaríamos
tratando con crecimiento exponencial
crecimiento
y esto recuerda es porque cada vez que
aumentes x estaríamos multiplicando por
más y más y más eres que son mayores que
1 ahora si el valor absoluto de r es
menor que 1 entonces estamos tratando
con un decaimiento con un decaimiento
exponencial y esto es porque se reducirá
nuestra función cuando x aumenta y bueno
dejaré que piensen un poco en qué
sucederá cuando eres igual a 1 con que
estamos tratando en esta situación y
bueno es una pregunta capciosa ya que
pero bueno de hecho les contaré
si eres igual a 1 entonces r elevado a
la equis siempre va a ser igual a 1
entonces todo esto se reduciría a la
ecuación de igual a amd la cual es la
ecuación de una recta constante de una
recta horizontal